less significant move would involve the
las vegas raiders signing
juju schmidt schuster from the steelers
that's a name to keep an eye on john
clayton was on radio in
pittsburgh yesterday and said that the
raiders are very interested in smith
schuster and that intrigues me they had
nelson aguilar in that
that slower than henry rugg's receiver
position
last year and i think that's the role
that juju smith
schuster can thrive in he's not a number
one guy he's not fast enough to be
number one he's not
game breaking enough to command double
coverage but he's
more than good enough to be a great
number two ruggs and smith schuster
would be awesome for the raiders shireen
and
you know from the steelers standpoint
you have to wonder if they got to the
point where number one they don't want
the cap space and number two
between the dancing on the logos and the
browns is the browns comment that helped
fire up cleveland before the playoff
game are the steelers just kind of ready
to move on from this guy
mike you know mds we know his stance on
running backs he thinks you can find
running backs anywhere the receiver core
with guys playing it in college in
college game going to so much passing i
think you can find receivers anywhere i
i would not spend a ton of money on juju
no matter who i am i just think you can
get better receivers out there
or as good of receivers as juju is he
has 1 000 yard season one pro bowl that
came in his thousand yard scenes and
when he was
named mvp of the team and we know what
happened with ab after that it kind of
spiraled out but you know i just don't
think you spend
a good deal of money on a receiver i
think you can find those guys you can
find them in the draft you can find them
in free agent they have hunter renfro to
play the slot i know juju's better
than a hunter infro he's better than
nelson aguilar i get that there
i just wouldn't spend a ton of money on
him if i'm the raiders but you know the
raiders are the raiders and they love
those
john gruden we know loves those old
players mike and he's gonna spend the
money where he sees fit and that just
might be juju
all those seven on seven camps high
school all those practices at the
college level the quarterbacks get the
reps in the receivers get the reps and
the receivers get better
and there are more and more great
receivers every year making it to the
nfl so that's a good point you don't
need to spend a lot of money
on a receiver as a veteran and the
steelers are the last team
to have to do it because they have
cracked the code on finding great
receivers in the draft at every round
they've managed to do it and also it
would be a nice little middle finger by
the raiders to antonio brown
after things went so haywire between
brown and the raiders to go get juju
miss schuster and maybe he'll be the
raiders mvp
in 2021 hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports